well scientists are sending a message to
those who are skeptical of global
warming because of the arctic blast the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration known as NOAA tweeted
this cartoon yesterday explaining winter
storms don't prove that global warming
isn't happening now this comes a day
after President Trump tweeted quote in
the beautiful Midwest wind chill
temperatures are reaching minus 60
degrees what the hell is going on with
global warming please come back fast we
need you Noah told CBS news it's tweet
was not in response to the president's
tweet chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn
of our New York station wcbs-tv is here
to put this arctic cold into perspective
and it's really frustrating reading a
tweet like that from the President of
the United States because this really is
the definition of global warming and
climate change right it is freezing here
it is scorching hot in Australia I mean
you get oftentimes you get those
extremes now you cannot negate global
warming because of this event right now
I mean all you do numbers are not going
to lie to anybody if you just just plot
the numbers NASA did it NASA plotted
every single year they plotted the
average temperatures okay we back to
that graphic for you right there and by
going from all the data from 1884 to
today is that line going up is the earth
getting warmer or is it going down is it
getting colder it's clearly guys going
up the earth is getting warmer we know
that so now the question becomes do
these big cold events we're getting
right now and negated and it really
doesn't because you know bianna you were
saying what we're seeing all this
extreme heat as well often times they
come coupled together mean right now
today you're having some readings down
to 37 degrees below zero that's an
actual temperature reading in Minnesota
I'm not windshield those are actual
temperature readings then you go to the
other side of the globe and I can show
you the extreme heat that you're talking
about five days ago all within sort of
the same sort of time period Australia
had 28 cities that recorded their
all-time record high temperatures not
for a date but the record high ever
recorded 121 degrees at marble beach in
Australia the problem is we're getting
more of those big heat events than we
are the big cold event so the overall
average of the year goes up so explain
that how that polar vortex then forms
that causes this cold weather you know
the polar vortex became like this
catchphrase back in 2015 just because it
became sort of a baby of the media if
you will all a vortex means is a
circular
okay polar means at the pole so you have
this circulating air that's very very
cold there and it doesn't circulate in a
perfect circle okay it elongates at
times it'll drop a piece down into a
place like Siberia this time he gets
dropping it down into the northern
plains and like I said it happened
before 2015 it will undoubtedly happen
again it's happening right now but just
climate change caused more polar
vortexes all right there's the big
question right I believe you can make
the parallel okay if we accept those
numbers that I showed you from NASA
pretty darn reputable source right and
we show you that the the temperature is
going up the Earth's getting hotter
what does heat do heat no creates lift
right and the faster that that air rises
the more the weather is gonna be
volatile on the other end if air goes up
very slowly slow rising air okay get
weather that's kind of moderate fast
rising air the hot of the areas of how
the hotter the earth is the faster the
air rises that's what brings about these
extreme weather and also one of the
reasons we're seeing more and more of
these massive hurricanes right well it's
all it's all relate if you notice in
that in that that tweet that NOAA put
out they showed the kettle over the
ocean because I hear I'm talking about
all this rising air and hot hot air well
people are think it's so cold outside
it's the middle of winter here in the
Northeast but remember your sea surface
temperature is a source of heat in the
winter I know it sounds crazy but it is
it's dramatically warmer than the
temperature on the land so that causes
the air to rise and that makes the
teakettle
you know percolate that steam rises and
creates the storms that you're getting
that's a good way to explain it Lonnie
thank you sure thank you